hi my name is Megan Trainor and this is
my beautiful gorgeous husband Daryl
Samara and we are gonna take a BuzzFeed
quiz to see how well we know each other
well that was so good yeah I think we're
gonna crush this thing you wanna a sit I
think a plus buzz oh I'm nervous now
let's hope it's gonna be great
what's my birthday December anniversary
December 22nd 1990 three ways to do the
year because I'm I need you with me I
need okay June 14 1995 up your sign is a
Gemini you're technically a Capricorn
but I think you're Sagittarius Jack
check your phone over
that's what weekly and then your number
is blah blah you don't know no I know it
oh I'm so bad yeah okay great
their eye color don't look at me okay
it's brown yeah you're blue but
sometimes they turn green oh your coffee
order okay I'm gonna go with Minds easy
now black yeah pretty much or a mushroom
coffee black
yeah craters right now is iced vanilla
latte with almond milk yeah their pizza
preferences oh this is easy
Aziz Megan only likes garlic on our
pizza but we do like the cauliflower
crust just but what's my main name like
some people get pepperoni or mushroom
cheese pizza there it is yeah
you eat each piece that will be nowadays
with the cauliflower crust that's right
fresh brothers we love you we love you
your favorite meal Lou this might be
tough for you I mean your old go to
before we figured out your heart thing
with the nutritionist was steak and eggs
I'm gonna go with yeah but then the
nutritionist was like hey your heart
records show that in a few years if you
don't get the fat of the meat the fat of
the meat out of your diet you're gonna
pop robbers yeah so wisdom and now are
vegetarians well thank you yeah that was
my favorite meal okay so now a meal now
I know your favorite like cheat snack um
the crunchy cinnamon swirl things what
are they called from from Hugo's sticky
bun was my food your I mean pizza yeah
favorite dessert okay you love the
sticky buns you love ice cream we love
it all yeah gigging amateur Oh a
doughnut boys when we walk by places
with doughnuts he's like I gotta look
away what's my favorite dessert you I
mean right that's made in love that's
like my naughty thing Oh Billy I got
drunk last night and I don't even it's
not even double stuffed it's mega stuff
I got stuffed Oreos I have a problem
your favorite movie this is impossible
it's hard you can't just narrow it down
to one just name one of them right now
it's the Joker
yeah the joke
right your favorite movie Spy Kids no
yeah favorite book ooh
this is a trick question your favorite
book I'm gonna go with I don't think I
know this one right I do my hair but my
favorite book is Catcher in the Rye ah
didn't do that not gonna check that
deserve it I mean I don't think I'm
gonna get this one either cuz that your
favorite book is you know this do I know
but you know the answer
Harry Potter no I don't read books I
mean I was the answer you could've won
all right we both laugh about that sign
their celebrity crush this is so easy it
hurts
mmm Shia LaBeouf Alaba the kid worship
Shia LaBeouf you like his amazing act
I'm telling you when I walk in on him
like if he's alone watching YouTube
videos Shia LaBeouf it's anything
Johnson interesting dude no he wants to
be his best friend and maybe yeah chef
you need a friend I also need a friend
hey I'm here and your celebrity crush oh
you have so many I have so many I mean
Leah oh of course
Oh lovely Oh I mean everybody we just
thought what who would you see Henry
Winkler he's the man Jevons
still love beloved love you Zac Efron I
knew it was it's like a bunch of um
there's a bunch Halle Berry oh my god
I'm kiss them all you know your
favourite swearword well I'm a foul
mouth so you hear me say what a lot yeah
yeah Gooden is my yeah do you say you're
much better than me yeah it's like I
said okay all right mom's here their
favorite subject in school
well this kid claims there's no proof
yet but he claims to get on or point oh
I have it somewhere
get out of here Bob no Bruin will you
have and I don't believe you but I mean
you told me once that you thrived in
math yeah is it bad
I love math I want to say yours is
English no you got a wrong you better
come on I was in band band bro
my their favorite band or singer this
I'm gonna lose but I mean it best to be
me of course but besides you you love
Coldplay that's all I want
okay who do I like hey you love you love
Britney you love and think about free
boys you get it you coming back he's
coming back their favorite TV show man
there's so much so many but there
actually is one TV show that you haven't
watched it is my favorite TV show and
you still won't watch it oh my gosh it
Breaking Bad Breaking Bad easy God good
it is your favorite TV show dare I say
prank
Wow that's yeah yeah I just did a cover
there's theme song - worst job they ever
had I got this I don't even know the
worst job I ever had but yeah go for it
I would say being a busboy or that what
that's a thing it was a bad job it was a
good Johnny win the game uro a Jesse
where I don't know other jobs you had
and I just you know what you don't know
this but I'll tell you whoa you don't
get it you don't get to check the box
fine but I had to babysit like a couple
times
wow do they know this I just I was just
stress the entire time I was like what
happens if you get up I mean you've just
been a songwriter your whole life I mean
you played like coffee shops so I have a
wonder that I do my first job I don't
know yes my games over there what do my
parents do oh oh I don't know if I can
check this one now you can you worked at
the jewelry store that suck I'm sorry
mom I love you so much I couldn't even
go on Facebook like oh yeah they like
there was rules their biggest pet peeve
you know what people do to me all the
time it's not fair there's something
wrong with the universe I got it somehow
you have this a crazy luck that every
time you like look out a window or like
look down the street you see someone
Hawking a loogie Hawking a loogie and I
snap in them
I'm surrounded by spit and I
so grow is so nasty thanks to the hello
every bank is my pain you know with me
personally is a good one
this better be a check because this is
you know the hell that you know ok one
thing he doesn't mind how much I burp
and how loud they are fun but he really
gets upset if I'm on a business call or
if I'm gonna call in general and I start
burping like like it's just rude and
it's not rude it's muted its dad and
it's my people it's my I know but like
there were various and he's like could
you not be a monster and I never say
that I know but that's what it feels
like their favorite sexual position
visualize this well yeah um your your
old-school old good ol missionary yes
yeah I like the eye contact no I don't
love it goes last if you mail the mesh
you can do anything you could do
anything let's just he likes it all how
about that right fine yeah fine okay
there kink what is this their favorite
kinky weird thing oh my god worse yeah
we're so lame what picture sex toys I
know no one okay me no one will believe
me but I believe yeah because I believe
it was BuzzFeed you like ripped on my
toe shoes yeah just like I gave him a
hike you know heaven call he looks weird
in them listen no one will ever believe
me I bought it for a friend because she
couldn't get hers in their mailbox she
was living with her dad at the time and
didn't want her dad to see her dildo gum
in the mail just oh good alright I'm a
good friend and I said you know what I
love this store downstairs I'll go pick
that out for you sometimes he likes a
lot of like my hairstyles like I'm like
oh my god cute braids
keep them for later you know or like
cool glasses are you're wearing keep it
more later we're married so that's we're
basically 50
a fish okay you won by 1 out of 20 on
this list one by one we're sharing all
that information we win by default I won
I only got 17 hmm I win everything all
of our winners I win except girls
warrants cuz he's more athletic than me
yeah
check out my new song wave featuring
Mike Sabbath just dropped recently
thanks for watching our girls videos
[Music]